When people entertain at home,
the biggest mistake they make is kind of
overreaching.
They try to do too much.
They try to make the bread and then they
make the cream spinach and then they
make the roast beef,
you know,
and then they've got to make the,
the red velvet cake for dessert.
You don't need to do all of that.
I think,
you know,
green salads,
you buy some green salads at the green
marker and throw some goat cheese and
some grape tomatoes and that's your side
dish.
You put a roast in the oven and that's
your entree,
you know,
and maybe you buy a beautiful pancake
and put some elaborate sorbet that you
bought.
I mean you need to keep it simple.
You want to have a good time,
you don't want to be frazzled.
This is about having a good time,
you know,
and people are just so happy to be
invited into your home.
And,
and you know,
it should not be a hassle for you.
It,
it be something that you really look
forward to doing and you show off.
Maybe one dish you make one thing that's
fancy.